eat breakfast with me at church
I'm Coptic Orthodox
so this Sunday was Palm Sunday
Next Sunday is Easter
Orthodox calendar is different than American Christian
and right now I'm showing you guys macarona bechamel
this is basically an Egyptian lasagna
it's penne pasta with a meat sauce and then a bechamel sauce on top
but since in our religion you're supposed to fast until Easter
meaning basically you're vegan till Easter
this is I believe
meat and dairy free
Egyptians love to eat with a spoon for some reason
so here's me struggling to eat this with a spoon
this is by far my favorite Egyptian food
next I'm washing it down with Egyptian apple soda delicious
honestly the sodas in Egypt are so much better than the sodas in America
10 out of 10
next I'm gonna show you guys mahshi
this is basically stuffed grape leaves
typically it's stuffed with rice and um
ground beef but because again
we're fasting
it's just rice
and these are honestly very good for being vegetarian
I guess vegan
but to this day
the best mahshi I ever had is my aunts
she painstakingly rolls them all by hand by herself
makes literally hundred passes out to family like
she is phenomenal
I'm wrapping up the leftovers to give to my family
this mass went on so long (longer than usual, past 1pm!)
it was 12:30 we've been there since 9:30
I was tired
this is dessert
it's basically Egyptian künefe
I think there's another name
but I can't remember
and it's like shredded filo dough with cheese and then simple syrup
honestly phenomenal
to this day besides family
the Egyptian church is the only place that I've had
Egyptian food that's actually good
otherwise in a restaurant just never hit the same as church or family
I don't like filming myself in public
so I was like
looking around the entire time
but yeah it was all delicious
and thank you for sticking around and watching me have breakfast in church
Happy Palm Sunday
I love you guys so much okay